Jupiter is the king of the solar system, the
king has a crown!
But, like, what’s it made of?
Jupiter, has auroras.
We’ve known this for a while, Hubble spotted
them.
But they’re not regular auroras, they are
the most powerful in the solar system.
Earth could fit inside this loop.
Yeah.
CH-YEAH.
It’s awesome.
So, before you ask, yes, Jupiter’s aurora
is like ours, only larger, except that it
is completely not like ours at all.
On Earth, electrons in the magnetic field
in our atmosphere get excited by the sun’s
energy and bump into air particles lighting
up the skies.
So, scientists thought they’d find something
similar on Jupiter.
Turns out, nuh-uh.
We don’t understand what is causing Jupiter’s
auroras, exactly.
NASA’s ideas are “all wrong” Isn’t
that fantastic?
Using a detector called JEDI, (I love nerds)...The
Juno probe orbited our jovial planet repeatedly,
taking measurements of its magnetic field.
We knew Jupiter’s magnetic field is the
strongest of any planet in our solar system,
which should make big aurora, but it turns
out it’s smaller than expected.
AND the aurora don’t behave like Earth’s
at all which may defy the laws of physics!
To say the least, it’s baffling.
And a new study says the electrons that cause
the aurora might be propelled faster by waves
in the magnetic field itself…
To energies as high as 400,000 volts!
But sometimes the energies are way lower,
Or are firing in weird random directions.
The researchers who are studying Juno’s
data think, the electrons are like tiny electrically
charged surfers… accelerating on a wave
of energy.
But why the unstable random generation and
the weird waves?
Shrug.
That likely comes from deep within the planet...
and may have something to do with Jupe’s
radiation belts… we just don’t know enough
yet!
Pulsars, some exoplanets and other star types
(like white dwarfs) can spit lots of radiation
and have magnetic fields that can wreak havoc
on spacecraft.Learning how Jupiter works could
help us build future spacecraft, and keep
them safe as we explore space.
It’s like learning how to build a boat that
can survive lightning strikes or the toughest
storms.
But instead it’s for the nasty space weather
we know we’ll encounter.
To paraphrase Captain Sparrow, “Bring me
that event horizon.”
Going to space is expensive, so if you want
to do it, you’d better learn to keep track
of your finances.
FreshBooks, is an online invoicing and accounting
software that can help.
Their software lets you manage your finances
or finances for a business!
You can send clean and professional looking
invoices in about 30 seconds.
With literally 2 clicks you can set yourself
up to receive payments online.
You can even take pictures of receipts on
your phone using FreshBooks’ mobile apps.
This makes claiming your expenses a million
times easier.
For a 30-day unrestricted trial, go to FreshBooks.com
slash Seeker, and enter “Seeker” in the
“How You’ve Heard About Us” section.
Sweet Jumpin’ Jupiters, please take a second
and subscribe to our show.
We actually visited the place that studies
our aurora from the arctic, it’s called
EISCAT.
Watch more here!
Before plunging into Jupiter on a death glide,
Juno learned about the planet’s origins,
looked for a solid core, mapped its magnetic
fields, measured compounds in the atmosphere
and observed auroras.
RIP Juno.Thanks for watching.